er mein versprechen gegeben bild hat ein
versprechen gegeben all die menschen in
den fluggast rufen gebieten die lassen
wir nicht alleine vor allem im a teil wo
133 menschen in dieser katastrophe
gestorben sind wir werden immer wieder
fragen was brauchen sie ja so wie jetzt
bei unserem zweiten flut stammte stars
heute seite 2 und 3 von unser bild
zeitung sie sehen wie dieser flut
stammtisch aussah dort in ahrweiler zu
hören was die größten sorgen sind woran
fehlt wo fühlen sie sich alleine
gelassen aktuell und zugehört haben wir
auch dieser mutter jennifer knapp hat
was sich aktuell immer noch am meisten
aufregt ist dass immer noch die kinder
vergessen werden sie müssen sich
vorstellen in die kinder haben keinerlei
zuflucht mehr die wenn sie raus wollen
spielen sie im dreck sie spielen im
matsch sie spielen im staub die haben
keine fußballplätze mehr keine
spielplätze mehr die haben keinen ort
mehr wird sie sich auch außerhalb der
katastrophe einfach mal treffen können
unglaubliches leben denn da jetzt in
diesem nach dieser flutkatastrophe
jennifer knapp hat ihre schilderung
haben uns so sehr berührt und werden
dann als stärker auf die kino ausmacht
die kinder vom urteil die kinder der
flut die jetzt aufwachsen in einem
zerstörten zu hause ohne geregelten
alltag mit frust mit verzweiflung und
jedes kind kennt jemanden der in der
flut gestorben ist viele haben mit
eigenen augen ansehen müssen wie
bekannte freunde vom wasser mitgerissen
worden sie haben tote gesehen und jetzt
jetzt geht dieser kinderalltag weiter im
aartal aber das ohne wirklichen
spielerischen alltag familie knappert
hat uns das mal gezeigt
zerstörte fenster aufgerissene böden
überall schutt und schlamm
das alles ist das ergebnis der
jahrhundertflut in deutschland der flut
von der auch die stadt bad neuenahr
ahrweiler in rheinland pfalz so stark
betroffen war und sie trifft diese
katastrophe besonders die kinder wie den
neunjährigen milow knabbert traurig
steht er auf dem sportplatz seiner
ehemaligen grundschule in altenburg und
nur langsam realisiert er was ihm diese
flut alles genommen hat die schule
ist jetzt kaputt und das ist selber auch
schlimm für mich waren die schule so
gewohnt und meine ganzen freunde waren
ja auch der schule und die meisten
zuletzt wegen dem hochwasser sind die
alle weg gezogen weil ihre haupt ball
ihre häuser kaputt sind die flut hat
nicht nur altenburg zerstört sondern
auch mein los klasse auseinander
gerissen seine freunde wurden auf
verschiedene schulen aufgeteilt viele
sieht er wegen der weiten wege kaum noch
nachmittags gemeinsam spielen dafür gibt
es keinen ort klagt seine mutter
jennifer knappert die arzthelferin ist
verzweifelt fühlt sich von den behörden
allein gelassen unsere ganze heimat
alles was unser tal aufgemacht hat es
weg
es ist weg das ist alles einfach weg
ihre sorge die kinder könnten ihre
lebenslust verlieren auf lange sicht
depressiv werden corona wäre schon
schlimm gewesen doch die folgen der
jahrhundertflut werden noch
katastrophaler sie fordert die politiker
auf endlich zu handeln damit ein
normales leben für die kinder wieder
möglich ist
wer ein normaler alltag in diesem
katastrophengebiet für kinder aber wie
soll das gehen darüber wollen wir
sprechen mit dem kinderpsychologen
sebastian placzek bei uns zugeschaltet
ist schon guten morgen herr mateschitz
kind zu sein dort aktuell im aatal in
diesem flug katastrophengebiet wie kann
wie soll das gehen
ja das ist schwierig ist es möglich aber
man muss natürlich schauen was muss
jetzt an bedarfslagen bei den kindern
entstanden und wie können wir ihn
dadurch helfen
das ist genau die zentrale frage wie
können wir ihnen dadurch helfen wir
können auch die eltern in den
betroffenen familien den kindern dadurch
helfen sie sind ja in ihren grundfesten
so nämlich an erschüttert in ihrem
glauben uns kann nichts schlimmes
passieren das versucht man ja auch als
eltern immer diese welt zu geben hier
kann nichts passieren und plötzlich
werden kinder erzeuge einer solchen
katastrophe wie kann man also diese
grundfeste die in ihn selig erschüttert
sind als eltern auch wieder aufbauen
es ist wichtig vor allem erst mal ruhig
zuhören es ist wichtig die kinder nicht
mit fragen zu bedrängen immer wieder
gespräche anzubieten zu dem thema
auch fragen offen und ehrlich
beantworten auch fragen wie kann das
noch mal passieren nicht kinder an lügen
sondern sagen ich weiß es nicht nur so
und wenn man dann merkt dass
veränderungen beim kind auftreten die
über so das normale hinaus gehen dann
macht es wahrscheinlich auch mal sind
kräfte
therapeuten und gesagt zum hinten nur
sind das jahr hunderte tausende kinder
die genau diese unterstützung brauchen
das heißt da wird nicht überall ein
kinderpsychologe wie sie gerade zur
seite stehen können da werden auch die
eltern vermutlich nicht diese zeit
gerade haben die haben selber solche
probleme haben selber so viel sorgen im
kopf also die sorge dass die kinder
tatsächlich gar keine hilfe bekommen in
diesen zeiten ist vermutlich berechtigt
ja wir haben das schon länger dass so
viel zu wenig kinder und
jugendpsychotherapeuten haben das sagen
wir seit jahrzehnten das wird jetzt dann
nochmal offenbar werden wir haben kein
flächendeckendes
psychologisches krisen management für
solche sachen etabliert obwohl auch das
seit jahren durchaus sinnvoll wäre
heisst ja die eltern stehen teilweise
nicht so gut da muss man ganz offen
sagen man kann nur hoffen dass
vielleicht über die schuhe die haben ja
infrastruktur oft noch von
schulpsychologen was passieren kann aber
ich will wird das bitten muss offen
sagen gehen sie davon aus dass es so was
wie eine kinder generation flut dort
geben wird
also die flut wir die kinder auf jeden
fall prägen das wird meine sache sein
die die kinder in irgendeiner form
verarbeiten müssen nicht alle kinder
werden daraus
nachteile gebiete und so weiter leben
mitnehmen aber ich glaube schon dass
dieses ereignis sehr präsent lagen wird
und dass man genau hinschauen sollte bin
wie betroffen hat
sie sagten es gebe anzeichen auf die man
auch als eltern achten müsste weil man
merkt sie dieses trauma dieser angst
dieses ereignisses ist zu viel für die
kinder da passiert jetzt was in ihnen
das können wir als eltern nicht mehr
auffangen da brauchen wir hilfe was sind
das wahrzeichen genau die sind bei
kindern bisschen anders als bei
erwachsenen da wären so sachen wie
bauchschmerzen
albträume
unrealistische ängste
kopfschmerzen
mitunter aggression gegenüber anderen
die aus dem nichts kommen und
tatsächlich sind auch sachen ein denkbar
wie ein essen oder ein quoten
erwartet nun habe ich schon kurz über
die eltern gesprochen die er selber so
viel im kopf haben verständlicherweise
dort in diesen zeiten und einfach auch
so viel zu tun haben so viel stress habe
so viel frust haben wie wichtig ist es
dass die eltern sich vor ihren kindern
sozusagen zusammenreißen oder soll man
das alles die probleme miteinander ganz
offen besprochen besprechen auch die
sorgen der eltern mit den kindern
es ist ein schmaler grat es gibt
erwachsenen themen die müssen
erwachsenen themen bleiben da geht es um
sachen wie beispielsweise finanzielle
sachen der wohnort grundsätzliche
gesundheitliche sachen das sollte man
gerade von jüngeren kindern
möglichst fernhalten andererseits
natürlich dürfen kinder auch mit kriegen
wenn eltern traurig sind und sich eltern
sorgen machen nur sollte man
idealerweise aus solchen gesprächen
irgendwie versuchen so schwer es den
eltern auch fallen wird mit so einem
positiven und wir gehen da jetzt fangen
wir wissen nicht wie es wird aber wir
kriegen das schon hin rauszugehen
ein schmaler gerade eine schwierige
situation für kinder aber auch für
eltern in den flutkatastrophen gebieten
herr badisch vielen herzlichen dank für
ihre einschätzungen
und wir schauen direkt ins wispertal
auch eine region die besonders betroffen
ist von der flut und in heimerzheim
348 kinder im alter von fünf bis zehn
jahren sind bisher dort auf eine schule
gegangen doch durch die flutkatastrophe
wurde dort der gesamte keller und das
erdgeschoss mit sieben klassenräume und
zwei betreuungsräume komplett zerstört
uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt regie martin
es der vorsitzende vom förderverein für
schulmaterial an der schule in swisttal
guten morgen schön dass hier bei uns
sind natürlich die wichtigste frage wie
geht es jetzt den kindern die sonst dort
auf die schule gehen wo sind jetzt
überall untergebracht wenn überhaupt
unterrichtet und haben sie auch in
irgendeiner art ja eine art alltag den
sonst ja die schule auch bieten kann
das problem ist tatsächlich so dass hier
in den letzten wochen jetzt nach der
flut jack eine gewisse kontinuität gab
warum man prinzipiell sehr anstrengen
die kinder haben er bis zu den
herbstferien jetzt und dienstags bis
samstags schule gehabt montags nutzten
die familien entscheiden wie sie
irgendwie über die runden kommen die
meisten arbeiten und hat natürlich ein
betreuungsproblem man konnte das kind
dann dementsprechend in der not befreien
anmelden war ja dadurch hat er das kind
mit sechs tage woche wir selber auch nur
einen tag am wochenende wo wir uns
erholen konnten wird man das erholung
nennen kann und dass dass er natürlich
schon seit geraumer zeit an jemanden die
gerade auch schon
erläutert wurde sind hier alle sehr
erschöpft mittlerweile langsam geht die
kraft zu ende und dann kommen wir diese
probleme mit der schule in der form dazu
derzeit in die kinder noch in der
gesamtschule untergebracht nach den
herbstferien
sollen ein teil der kinder die erst
zweite klasse in die einzige grundschule
zurück steht aber noch ein gutachten aus
ob die kinder dort können bezüglich
kontaminationen et cetera durch schmutz
geben
und das problem dass in der gesamtschule
oben ist die altersstruktur
verdeutlichte der schule frist nicht
kindgerecht aber nicht grundschule
gericht und die klassen ebenfalls nicht
dass das nächste zeit als die kinder
auch man jetzt möchte oder nicht eine
ganze menge mitgekriegt haben absolut
auf meine eigenen kinder sprachen davon
dass tote menschen mit hubschrauber weg
gebracht wurden
tatsächlich weiter waren menschen die
gerettet wurden aber das musste man den
kindern erst mal anständig erklären
und meiner meinung nach sollten gerade
noch diesen traumatischen erlebnisse die
die kinder mitgemacht haben hier
wäre schön gewesen wenn zumindest von
behördlicher seite alles relativ schnell
gegangen wäre und ein ganz normaler
schultag oder in anführungszeichen noch
war da schon einfach funktioniert hätte
das ist leider nicht der fall und daher
wissen wir jetzt noch nicht wie es
letztendlich nach den demonstrierenden
wohl
das nächste problem ist dass viele
kinder auch hier zuhause verloren haben
oder sogar in ihrem kaputten zu hause
leben und dann der rote schule in zürich
fehlt herr martinez sie haben von ihren
eigenen kindern ja auch gerade kurz
erzählt die haben die korona krise voll
miterlebt und erleben wir dass diese
flut katastrophe wie ver kindheit bleibt
ihnen
es bleibt nicht mehr viel übrig das
problem ist seit will ich schon gerade
sagten durch die korona krise schon eine
ganze menge stecke geblieben und habe
nicht verlangt oder habt ihr die von den
familien erlangt und jetzt letztendlich
durch die flut weber
ist das letzte bisschen was man noch
hatte man konnte auf dem spielplatz
geben
der chor ohne zeit oder oder andere
dinge machen aber mittlerweile meine ich
sogar fast den ort unten weil die
zerstörung ist immer noch vorhanden
jetzt auch über drei monate danach es
ist immer noch alles da unten ja in
schutt und asche die leute bemühen sich
und zogen aber
dann kommt einfach in der form nicht
mehr hinterher alles wieder in gang zu
bringen alles reparieren fühlen wir uns
auch hier ein wenig ich würde fast sagen
den stich gelassen das ist das was wir
immer wieder hören das hören wir aus dem
swisttal das haben ja aus ahrweiler
gehört und wenn es deswegen genauso
wichtig herr martin ist dass sie das
heute früh waldbild live mit ihren
worten einmal schildern wie aktuell
dieser verloren gegangene kinder alltag
auch bei ihnen auch in ihrer familie
aktuell aussieht danke für dieses
gespräch
[Musik]